if you were in the US illegally would
you say so on a census form that is the
subject of intense and emotional debate
tonight after the Commerce Department
announcement that a citizenship question
will be on the 2020 census this evening
correspondent Doug mackelway looks at
what that all means the administration
delivered the news quietly via press
release last night at 9:29 p.m. after
weeks of building controversy quote
today the US Department of Commerce
announced that a question on citizenship
status will be reinstated to the 2020
decennial census immigration groups
reacted with expected outrage
California's Attorney General
preemptively filed suit and tweeted
quote including the question is not just
a bad idea it is illegal supporters
noted the question had been included in
censuses up until the year nineteen
fifty there's no proof that it prevented
anybody from voting then and the
Attorney General of California Xavier
Becerra has sued saying it's
unconstitutional but it was never
unconstitutional before indeed in its
letter requesting to change last
December
DOJ noted citizenship data is quote
critical to important protections
against racial discrimination in voting
immigration rice groups reject that
rationale we see this as an intimidation
factor designed to frighten immigrants
from not participating in the census
press secretary Sarah Sanders today
denied the change came from the White
House the White House supports it but
the decision was made at the department
level both sides agree that not
participating in the census skews the
data which helps determine the
allocation of government resources how
those districts are drawn has enormous
implications for how much political
representation you have or your chance
of your candidate winning or your voice
being heard in 2010 census takers
documented such a significant increase
in both legal and illegal non-citizens
living in California that the state
gained five congressional seats there
are also doubts whether a citizenship
question would substantially deter
immigrants from participating in the
census we do already ask this on a whole
series of other census questions not
only
citizenship but a whole detailed set of
related questions yet only 2.1 percent
of respondents failed to share
citizenship data New York Attorney
General Eric Schneiderman announced that
he will now join the California's
Attorney General leading a multi-state
lawsuit to preserve what he calls a
quote fair and accurate census right
mourn this for the panel Doug thank you